nouveau numéro de reporter sur france24
direction les états unis pour tenter de
comprendre un phénomène inédit baptisé
la grande démission depuis le début de
la pandémie de kovy 19 ils sont des
millions de travailleurs à avoir donné
leur démission et à ne pas souhaiter
reprendre leur travail d'avants famille
allard bonjour vous êtes correspondante
de france 24 aux états unis dans le
reportage qu'on va découvrir vous donner
la parole à d'anciens salariés qui ont
renoncé à revenir dans leurs précédentes
emploi quel est leur point commun mais
écouter ils ont en commun d'évoluer dans
un univers de l'emploi très dynamique et
volatile où les employés sont peu
syndiqués et au contrairement à la
france le statut des travailleurs est
fragile mais surtout ils ont en commun
d'avoir pris conscience et d'avoir
décidé de changer de vie et profiter de
ce moment pour faire évoluer leurs
conditions de travail et cela malgré les
profils très différents car comme vous
allez le découvrir dans ce reportage
cette grande des missions concernent
tout le pays alors on part aux états
unis avec ce reportage que vous avez
signé avec matthieu mabin pour france 24
[Musique]
des klaxons de solidarité pour les
salariés de l'usiné kellogg's depuis
deux mois mais 1400 employés des quatre
antennes du géant céréaliers sont en
grève ici dans le tennessee ils se
relaient jour et nuit devant
l'entreprise pour réclamer de meilleures
conditions de travail pour tous les
salariés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les salariés de kellogg's protestent
contre un système de rémunération à deux
vitesses qui pénalise les nouveaux
employés payés 18 $ de l'heure contre 30
dollars pour les plus anciens
pour kevin bradshaw ouvriers et
représentant syndical le coc vide a
réveillé la solidarité
l'entreprise a gagné plus de 380
millions de dollars en neuf mois et
s'est attribué 158% de bonus alors que
nous n'avons obtenu un bonus que 2 500
dollars pour avoir risquer nos vies et
que plusieurs de nos collègues sont
morts dus qu'aux vives 19 nous avons
travaillé pendant toute la pandémie pas
te poses pas de jour allégé il nous
qualifié de héros et maintenant nous
sommes traités comme des moins que rien
mais le co vide a galvanisé les
travailleurs qui sont en train de
réaliser qu'ils ont travaillées se sont
sacrifiés pour enrichir ses entreprises
tous les jours et sans demander beaucoup
en effet
parmi les revendications des horaires de
travail décent car depuis le début de la
pandémie où la demande de céréales a
explosé aux états unis et les salariés
ont été mobilisés 12 à 16 heures par
jour sept jours sur sept ce jour-là
kellogg's proposent un compromis mais
l'accord est refusée à l'unanimité
nous les représentants syndicaux
soutenons ce que décident les
travailleurs ils ont décidé de refuser
cette proposition ça suffit kellock ce
n'est pas dans le besoin il tente juste
d'abuser de nous s'ils continuent nous
resterons en grève chaque jour de plus
est un jour nous sommes plus forts que
kevin travaille ici depuis 20 ans il est
en charge de l'emballage des céréales
avant distribution
ici c'est le département réception
l'expédition pour faire pression sur ses
salariés kellogg's menaces de tous les
remplacer ou de délocaliser si la grève
ne cessent pas mais pour kevin cette
stratégie de la peur ne fonctionne plus
ils savent qu'ils ne peuvent pas
fonctionner sans kellogg's existe grâce
à nous parce que nous ne sommes
kellogg's en ce moment ils ont des
travailleurs qui se fiche d'être là
qu'il n'arrive pas à garder parce qu'il
démissionne du jour au lendemain ils
pensent pouvoir nous mettre la pression
en menaçant de nous remplacer qui
après presque trois mois de grève un
accord a été trouvé entre kellogg's et
ses salariés une victoire syndicale qui
fait écho à plusieurs autres mouvements
de grève inédit dans le pays
[Musique]
ce
chauny
le que 8,19 à bouleverser le marché de
l'emploi dans tous les secteurs les
patrons peine à recruter c'est le cas de
farhat othmani qui gère une société de
limousines à memphis
avant la pandémie il avait six
chauffeurs pour ses 14 voitures il n'en
a plus aucun aujourd'hui
j'ai désespérément besoin de chauffeurs
mais je n'en trouve pas j'essaie de
recruter j'ai besoin d'au moins trois
chauffeurs pour maintenir mon activité
actuelle c'est pour ça que je conduis
moi même ma femme et moi nous faisons
facilement 90 à 100 heures de conduite
par semaine
je dirais qu'au mois d'août et septembre
dernier j'ai perdu au moins 3000 $ par
semaine parce que je suis obligé de
refuser des courses
en plus de son activité de limousines
farhat et le gérant de ce café du centre
de la ville ici recruter n'est pas plus
facile l'établissement fonctionne grâce
à une seule serveuse et au patron lui
même anna wohlfahrt la cas j'aurais
jamais imaginé préparer moi même les
boissons à whitby merrimack blanks
quand j'ai ouvert ce qu'a fait des
premières années c'est pas comme ça que
je vois les choses non habits
de rhisnes b x ena batna mais avec la
pandémie le manque de travailleurs je
suis bien obligé de faire ce qu'il faut
pour prendre soin des clients et qu'elle
réclame et prendre soin mon commerce
ce matin là farhad fait passer un
entretien d'embauché à un jeune homme
qui hésite entre deux offres d'emploi
alors pour être certain de le recruter
farhat est prêt à offrir plus que le
salaire minimum de 7 $ 25 de leurs dans
le tennis tu seras payé à l'heure toutes
les deux semaines et je gagnerai combien
de commencer à 8 dollars 5 de leurs
puces les pourboires si tu travailles
les matins tu te feras facilement une
moyenne de 19 20 $ de l'heure et à
partir de là si tu restes avec moi je
t'augmente rennes je souhaite vraiment
que tu viennes travailler avec jusque
début septembre les chômeurs recevaient
une aide fédérale de 300 $ par semaine
destinés à soutenir la population
impactés par le colis mais le tennessee
comme 25 autres états a mis fin à cette
aide dès le mois de juin dans l'espoir
que cela pousserait les américains à
retourner au travail les chiffres
portent en indique pas de reprise
significative de l' embauche en novembre
quatre millions et demi d'américains ont
quitté leur emploi un nombre jamais
atteint en 20 ans
je crois que les gens prennent
conscience que leur temps est précieux
par exemple moi j'ai quitté un boulot
six mois après le début de la pandémie
ce n'était pas très épanouissant je ne
me plaisait pas moi j'aime travailler en
communauté comme dans les casiers alors
c'est sûr je gagne beaucoup moins bien
ma vie mais je suis aussi beaucoup plus
heureux que dans un bureau toute la
journée
c'est aussi le cas pour les gens qui
travaillaient dans des fast-foods et qui
se disent qu'ils valent mieux que ça ils
ont le droit de faire quelque chose
qu'ils aiment
comme nick les travailleurs américains
semblent avoir changé de priorité c'est
notamment le cas pour les familles la
fermeture des écoles au début de la
pandémie a contraint de nombreux parents
à s'organiser différemment
elisabeth nottingham et orthophoniste de
formation mère de trois enfants elle a
démissionné en juin 2020 pour leur faire
classe elle même car ils n'arrivaient
pas à suivre les cours en ligne
c'est un travail en constante évolution
quand nous avons commencé ce n'était pas
vraiment par choix c'est parce que tout
a fermé
d'un coup les enfants étaient à la
maison et au début j'ai essayé d'être
très strictes et académiques
à 9h mathématiques à 10h récréation à
11h science
ça a marché un temps et puis nous avons
évolué vers notre propre manière de
faire plus naturel
démissionner n'a pas été une décision
facile pour cette femme ayant travaillé
toute sa vie désormais le foyer dépend
uniquement des revenus du père de
famille mais le couple a décidé ensemble
de continuer ce système éducatif malgré
la réouverture des établissements
privilégiant ainsi le bien-être au
confort financier
continuer l'école à la maison cette
année était la bonne décision pour le
wef ça nous permet d'avoir le contrôle
tout est encore tellement incertain on
ne sait pas si les écoles vont à nouveau
fermé et recommencer l'enseignement en
ligne
et puis avant le covin nous étions une
famille très occupé nous courions par
tous les enfants étaient dans le bus à
7h30 du matin nous nous dépêchons
d'aller au bureau puis de rentrer à la
maison pour faire les devoirs les leçons
de sport le dîner
nous avons ralenti le rythme et la
priorité est vraiment devenue la santé
et la sécurité de nos enfants et de
notre famille nous ne pouvons pas
revenir à la façon dont nous vivions
avant
un point de vue partagé par les enfants
d'elisabeth qui ne veulent pas retourner
à l'école publique
j'aime la flexibilité que permet l'école
à la maison certains jours je ne fais
rien si je n'en ai pas envie et d'autres
jours je travaille beaucoup et puis je
reçois plus d'attention individuelles
qu'à l'école avec une vingtaine d'autres
élèves dans ma classe
avant 2020 un peu plus de 5 % des
familles américaines déclaré faire école
à la maison en bientôt deux ans de
pandémie ce nombre a doublé et la
famille nottingham fait partie des
désormais 11 % d'américains ayant choisi
ce mode de vie
elisabeth reçoit ce jour là la visite
d'une de ses anciennes collègues karen
qui elle n'a pas quitté son emploi de
peur de ne pas s'en sortir
financièrement les deux femmes ne se
sont pas vus depuis le début de la
pandémie
alors comment ça se passe l'école à la
maison
ça a été un défi mais ça se passe bien
le plus dur pour moi ça a été de me
sentir privé de quelque chose j'avais
une carrière j'avais une vie en dehors
de ces captures
mais c'était mon choix de démissionner
et je sais que c'était la meilleure
chose à faire pour les enfants et pour
moi
elisabeth n'est pas la seule à avoir
quitté son poste huit de ses anciens
collègues ont quitté le cabinet médical
au cours des derniers mois et font tout
eux aussi partie de la grande démission
beaucoup de gens sont partis et pour des
raisons compréhensibles mais je n'ai
jamais vu autant de personnes
démissionner qu'au cours des deux
dernières années tout le monde aime
notre entreprise nous avons vraiment un
bon environnement de travail et pourtant
je sais que tout le monde pense à
démissionner
bien sûr j'ai pensé à reprendre mon
travail j'ai aussi eu quelques offres
d'emploi mais je ne peux pas y retourner
c'est difficile à expliquer je ne peux
pas c'est tout mon état d'esprit qui a
changé une fois qu'on a goûté cette
liberté c'est inimaginable de penser
travailler pour quelqu'un d'autre en
décembre
6,3 millions d'américains étaient sans
emploi alors que plus de 10 millions de
postes sont à pourvoir dans le pays des
chiffres qui révèlent un rapport au
travail profondément transformé dans une
amérique pourtant très capitaliste
à memphis nous retrouvons les grévistes
de kellogg's pour kevin bradshaw la
grande émission est la preuve que les
travailleurs ont enfin conscience de
leur valeur
je pense que la préco vite va dépendre
de la façon dont les entreprises veulent
vraiment survivre en investissant dans
leurs travailleurs si vous n'investissez
pas d'argent dans vos travailleurs si
vous faites passer le profit avant les
gens vous n'aurez pas de main d'oeuvre
mais les patrons ne veulent pas partager
le profit ils veulent tout le profit
mais en continuant de maximiser sur le
dos des gens vous obtiendrez ce que vous
avez maintenant des gens qui ne veulent
pas aller travailler il ne s'agit pas
d'une pénurie de main d'oeuvre mais bien
d'une crise des salaires
le problème ne date pas d'hier mais ça
peut plus durer maintenant plus que
jamais j'en ai marre de souffrir comme
ça c'est le signal d'alarmé par tous les
travailleurs sont en train de se
réveiller
[Musique]
et
pour la première fois dans l'histoire
des états unis le rapport de force s'est
inversé entre patrons et salariés les
travailleurs sont en position de force
et le revendique une tendance qui
pourrait bien devenir la norme les
salaires ont augmenté de plus de 4 et
demi pour cent en 2021 preuve de la
forte concurrence entre les employeurs
pour trouver de la main d'oeuvre
[Musique]
voilà pour cette grande des missions aux
états unis on retrouve fanny allard
notre correspondante fanny vous évoquez
dans votre reportage un rapport au
travail profondément modifiées mais
c'est le contrat de travail classique
qui n'est plus acceptée pas le travail
en lui-même
absolument ce qui a changé c'est la
manière dont les américains après on le
travaille avec cette pandémie des
millions d'entre eux montrent eu le
temps pour la première fois de leur vie
de s'interroger sur ce qu'ils ont
vraiment envie de faire et sur la
manière dont ils veulent le faire
autrement dit ils veulent travailler
pour vivre mais plus vivre pour
travailler les américains comme vous le
savez ont très peu de vacances par an
lorsqu'ils sont au chômage les
indemnités ne durent que 24 semaines ils
ont aussi moins d' avantages sociaux et
donc une liberté dans le travail bien
inférieure à celle que nous connaissons
en france et avec cette pandémie
certains ont découvert le travail à
distance et sont rendu compte que cela
leur donnait une vraie liberté de
mouvement mais aussi la possibilité de
passer plus de temps en famille tout en
étant aussi productif d'autres ont tout
simplement réalisé qu'il n'était pas
épanouis dans leur emploi et ont décidé
de changer de carrière et puis enfin
beaucoup de travailleurs ne veulent plus
accepter d'heures supplémentaires sans
être payé davantage et le contexte de
pénurie de travailleurs cette grande
émission qui fait l'objet du reportage
et bien leur donne un moyen de pression
inédit pour demander des augmentations
de salaires donc si vous voulez le
rapport de force est en quelque sorte
inversé oui on l'a on l'a vu notamment
dans le cas de cette usine kellogg's sur
lequel s'ouvre votre reportage alors
dans quelle mesure cette situation
peut-elle durer alors que les états unis
comme le reste du monde font face à une
inflation galopante
c'est la question que tout le monde se
pose est ce sur quoi mise d'ailleurs
certains employeurs pour l'embauché dans
les mois à venir l'inflation est
effectivement au plus haut depuis 1982
7% d'augmentation sur l'année 2000 21 ce
qui met en difficulté les américains
dans leur vie quotidienne d'autant que
les aides gouvernementales se sont
arrêtés il ya plusieurs mois déjà on
sait également que de nombreux
travailleurs ne sont pas encore
retourner sur le marché de l'emploi en
raison d'inquiétudes sanitaires mais si
vous voulez ils sont une manne en
sommeil et dès que le virus sera contenu
ils reviendront sur le marché du travail
ce qui risque de diminuer
considérablement le pouvoir de pression
qu'ont les employés à l'heure qu'il est
je vous propose d'ailleurs d'écouter à
ce sujet mark zandi économiste américain
qui a certes sur la situation dans les
mois à venir
les gens ont épargné pendant la pandémie
parce qu'ils ne pouvaient pas dépenser
mais l'argent commence à être dépensés à
nouveau les ressources s'amenuisent ce
qui veut dire qu'il va y avoir une
pression financière de plus en plus
importante sur les ménages à faible
revenu qui va les pousser à retourner au
travail
l'inflation a tellement augmenté qu'elle
pourrait peser sur le pouvoir d'achat
surtout si elle n'est pas prise en
compte dans les salaires à l'avenir ça
pourrait vraiment devenir un problème
voilà pour ce contexte donc de cette
grande émission aux états unis est ce ce
problème d'ailleurs touche d'autres pays
que les etats unis notamment la france
merci beaucoup pour ses explications
famille allard vous étiez avec nous
depuis washington vous êtes
correspondante pour france 24 c'est la
fin de cette émission merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro porté
sur france 2
[Musique]